ah the disappearing act one of the
oldest magic tricks in the book but to a
dog it's very new and disconcerting he
just had the treat right in front of his
nose and suddenly poof it's gone the
trickster is 35 year old Yosa ahonen of
Finland he makes the videos in the
Finnish town of tampa in the midst of
sub-arctic forests and lakes Yosa ahonen
has been performing all around Finland
for about 10 years to human audiences
but a few months ago he had dogs among
his spectators the first time I tried to
trick this is actually how you can do it
in home as well you don't need anything
to do this so could you sit thank you
and you hold to treat with your hand
like this so your fingers covers the
tree and you put the Treat on top of
your head and it got the dogs varied
reactions gave him an idea Yosa opponent
modified the trick and 27 dog owners and
his brother answered his facebook
invitation to take part his brother is
game for nearly anything it's always fun
to see your brother with a big dog and
maybe get attacked now he didn't exactly
get attacked but the reactions were
surprising
almost all the dogs fell for the trick
there's no known scientific explanation
for why the dogs neglected to make use
of their sense of smell dogs also good
like performers and they are like real
and honest and they don't fake anything
they are like what they are Conan who's
also a graphic designer edited the
footage into two videos that he titled
simply magic for dogs parts one and two
the first video went viral immediately
racking up nearly 15 million hits last
time we checked I uploaded it in youtube
in friday night i went to sleep and my
girlfriend woke me up i think on like
nine a.m. and shouted it gets like
40,000 views on youtube and that was
like what and by the end of the day was
million views and then i had like a
champagne bottle opened in August he was
bewildering canines yet again this time
with the levitating sausage trick many
animal behavior researchers are eager to
witness the video shoots first hand and
fan mail has come in from all over the
world several people have emailed the
same story that they were having a bad
day and they watched the video and they
felt great after it so I'm very happy
that we have like spread the happiness
around the world without this stupid
little dogmatic video how those react to
human walk in this video Yosa Allanon
has asked a friend who's a voice
imitator to help him see how dogs react
when humans begin to speak there
which it's also proving to be a hit for
our Honan who's having a howl with man's
best friend